[Music]
we are at the 11th month of this year
2023 how time flies does it anyway this
year has been A Feast for movie master
fans and here in this video we will
showcase 35 of them in ascending order
of sides we will showcase just the best
screenshots and scenes of these monsters
let's get to it the mantle Claw is a
crustacean super species to be seen in
Monarch the legacy of monsters this
month it is 5 m or 16.5 ft
tall the fola sucus is a gigantic
prehistoric reptile that appeared in the
movie called 65 it was 5.5 m or 18 ft
tall the T-Rex was yet another gigantic
reptile a dinosaur that appeared in the
same movie called 65 it is of the same
height
the mother longle is a super species of
Skull Island and will be seen this month
in the Monarch series it is 6 M or 20 ft
tall the abelisk was seen in the
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 in the
latest sequences of the movie it was
around 6 to 9 M or around 30 ft
tall so this one right here we decided
to call this the mini karathan and it
will appear in Aquaman the lost kingdom
this December it is 10 to 12 M around 36
to 40 ft long
the black dragon will be yet another
Super species that is set to appear in
the Monarch series the legacy of
monsters it is around 12 M of 40 ft tall
Abraham is a gorilla sent to space and
came down with alien DNA and became a
huge monster it was seen in the ape
versus Mecca Ape
movie the mecca ape was a government
designed gorilla robot that is the
antagonist of Abraham in a same movie
called ape versus Mecca
ape the the mole Titan is another bigger
Arctic super species that will be seen
in 2 weeks in Monarch the legacy of
monsters it is 18 M or 60 ft
tall the black demon was a shot that
appeared in the movie of the same name
it was a megaladon shock and it was 18 M
or 60 ft long the ravian is a gigantic
flying creature that was seen in the
Mandalorian series and was a desert
animal it was 20 M or 65 ft wide in
wingspan the leaden is a mythical dragon
made out of trees and wood and has
magical fire it was seen in Shazam 2 The
Fury of the
Gods the Kil chameleon is a Skull Island
super species that was seen in the
Netflix Kong Skull Island series The
Animated
one the mechs are gigantic shocks that
was stuck in the trench in the Pacific
Ocean they were released from there and
were seen in the Me 2 sequel the
trench the gigantic octopus is yet
another giant creature that escaped the
trench and was seen in the same me to
movie the sequel it was around 30 m or
100 ft
long the Dinosaur turtle is a gigantic
reptilian creature that was seen in the
Mandalorian series and was a desert
animal it was 30 m or 100 ft long The
Temper is a fat dragon that appeared in
Dungeons and Dragons no honor Amongst
Thieves it is around 30 to 40
m gal
was one of the kajus that came to life
in the gamra rebirth Netflix limited
series it was 50 m or 165 ft
tall Godzilla minus 1 is the Toho
incarnation of the king of the monsters
this year that is currently being
showcased in Japanese theaters right
now titanis skull was seen in the
Animated Series Skull Island in Netflix
and was bigger than his first merse
Incarnation at around 200 ft or 60 m
gamra is a protective kaju and a
guardian of the world seen in the gamra
rebirth series being around 60 M or 200
ft
tall Jager was another a second Kaiju to
fight against gamra in the rebirth
series and it resembles a Triceratops
dinosaur and around the same size as
gamra the Kraken was the main antagonist
in the Skull Island animated series and
was way bigger than Kong
there the mythosaur was slightly seen in
the Mandalorian series again even though
it was hyped for so long it is around 90
M
long hoshikuzu is a strange kaju that is
a central figure in the crowdfunded
movie called hosi
35 es gaus was the final enemy of gamra
in the rebirth series and it is a
mutated form of the gaus
Kaiju virus was supposedly the main
overarching kaju that would have brought
about the end of the world in
rebirth gyon was a fast metallic kaju
with a sord like snout that can cut
through anything even through G's
hand Godzilla of the moner US will be
seen again in Monarch series and it will
be seen as both the 2014 and the 2019
designs The Monkey King was a comical
character in the movie of the same name
and it had a good character development
plot it also grew to 150 m in
size The Dragon King was the ruler of an
underwater Kingdom and the antagonist of
The Monkey King and wanted to control
the entire world as an
immortal zigra was an aquatic kaju in
the rebirth series and could extend its
tail to several times its body
length
the trinar was the biggest creature ever
to be featured in the Mandalorian series
and is one of the biggest in Star Wars
as
well Unicron is always the main
overarching antagonist of the
Transformers movies and this time we saw
him in Rise of the
Beast so those are 35 gigantic movie
Monsters of
20123 anyway if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
monsters and creatur just then check out
our Channel and why you might just have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam